gestern bekannt geworden bild hat
darüber berichtet dass die kanzlerin und
ihr enger mitarbeiter kreis darüber
nachdenkt den lockdown noch zu
verschärfen da fragt man sich erst mal
was ist denn überhaupt noch möglich
erste berichte waren jetzt dass
beispielsweise der öffentliche
personennahverkehr eingestellt oder
zumindest reduziert werden soll was
haben sie da gehört was wissen sie
darüber also dass der öffentliche
personennahverkehr eingestellt werden
soll das kann ich nicht bestätigen
ich wüsste auch nicht mehr darüber
nachgedacht haben soll aber es ist
tatsächlich so warten machen uns große
sorgen wenn wir uns die infektionszahlen
anschauen wenn wir uns die todeszahlen
anschauen wenn wir uns zahlen aus
anderen ländern auch hier hinblick auf
das mutierte virus anschauen dann sind
wir alle in großer sorge und die
kanzlerin ist es auch das hat sie
gestern noch mal im bundesvorstand zum
ausdruck gebracht und jetzt werden wir
in den nächsten tagen miteinander
sprechen müssen und vor allem liegt es
jetzt an den zuständigen ministern und
den ministerpräsidenten gemeinsam mit
der bundeskanzlerin über das weitere
vorgehen zu sprechen und dann zu
entscheiden das heißt es stimmt auf
jeden fall dass man überlegt wo an
welchen momenten kann man nach schärfen
welche maßnahmen müssen noch zusätzlich
getroffen werden
ja wir machen das ja jeden tag bzw
diejenigen die dafür verantwortlich sind
tun dass jeden tag zu schauen welche
maßnahme hat welche wirkung wir haben
sich die zahlen entwickelt was es jetzt
in den letzten zwei wochen immer
passiert und was muss man jetzt ändern
werden eine zeit wo wir darüber
gesprochen haben wo kann man vielleicht
wieder maßnahmen zurücknehmen wenn die
zahlen steigen und infektionen zahlen
steigen was muss man jetzt noch
zusätzlich tun also das was sie
beschrieben haben ist ein dauernder
prozess der ist nicht jetzt so sondern
der war
klugerweise immer so an welchen
maßnahmen werden erst jetzt wenn wir das
schon beschlossen und beraten hätten
dann wäre das jetzt auch schon verkündet
das werden die beratungen jetzt der
nächsten tage zeigen zwischen der
minister zwischen den
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten und der
bundeskanzlerin rp zwei masken schlecht
beispielsweise darüber haben wir gestern
auch im vorstand nicht besprochen
gesprochen ist es auch keine partei
entscheiden ist und nicht parteipolitik
sondern es ist eine entscheidung die
jenigen die die verantwortung haben der
regierung in erster
linie auf der grundlage der gesetze die
die parlamente beschlossen haben
und wenn die entscheidung getroffen
werden ist das dann möglich dass die
nächste ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit
der kanzlerin vorgezogen wird
das ist möglich wenn das notwendig ist
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren